so Ennis how tall are you I don't know
seven foot so we're about the same
height excellent yeah not quite hurry up
gut felt all right let's go do the show
all right
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go keep clapping you're not done
yet
all right happy Tuesday everybody happy
Tuesday especially my fellow late night
hosts or what's left of them James
Corden is on his way back to England
but the rest of them are all shut down
because their writers are on strike and
that's one sure way to make those shows
funnier
who knew they had writers that's like
finding out Brian stelter had a personal
trainer
damn
never over but on Gutfeld My Writers
don't strike I strike the writers
[Music]
and that was for writing a good joke
anyway the only collective bargaining
around here is which one gets to shave
my back
yes but there's big news out of
Batesville Arkansas this week that has
to be the first time anybody ever said
that but hunter Biden finally appearing
in court over a contentious child
support battle the baby's mom been
fighting to keep her payments at 20
grand per month which is hard to keep it
a g string and 100 Watts that reduced
and I don't blame him all those foreign
energy jobs for unqualified crack
addicts have since dried up but
someone's got to take care of that kid
because according to her M.I.A Grandpa
there's no such thing as someone else's
child
no such thing as someone else's child
our nation's children are all our
children ah well that explains why he
never asks parents if he could sniff
their kids hair
that scalp belongs to everyone I think
that was John Wayne Gacy's High School
yearbook quote
I know it's too far yet Joe keeps on
ignoring his grandkid he's pretending
she doesn't exist so much it's starting
to make Kamala jealous
and Hunter claims the reason why he
denied being the dad was because he
can't remember the sex since he was
having so much of it with so many
partners dude now's not the time to brag
it's like when Bernie Sanders forgets
how many homes he has
worse Hunter doesn't even want to give
the tot his last name but at this point
why would anybody want the Biden name
it's more sullied than Joe's depends
after Mexican died at the nursing home
cafeteria and I've been there they
should just change it to a name with
less baggage you know like Cosby
yeah
of course it's no secret Hunter pocketed
Millions from Shady foreign deals and
cushy board positions but now his
lawyers argue that he's got nothing yeah
I guess Hunter must be paying the
lawyers in White House silverware
he wanted to sell his blood but how safe
is that I'd rather get a transfusion
from raw poultry
but apparently he has no salary his
Porsche was repossessed and he's forced
to sleep on a cot in his father's room
on that trip to Dublin a cot what is the
president booking Motel sixes
I hope Hunter brought quarters for the
vibrating bed
and Hunter's only income right now is
from his crappy expensive art he's
selling to well-heeled powerful buyers
with absolutely no political connections
whatsoever right now there's a filthy
rich businessman in Beijing taking a
dump in one of his eight bathrooms
staring at a half million dollar
painting that resembles a placemat
speckled with Skittle vomit
sounds pretty good actually by the way
those buyers names are kept under lock
and key apparently they're more
important to Joe than classified
documents
but look you know how Hunter could make
ends meet pretend the baby is a Coke
habit you seem to have no problem
finding cash for that anyway the judge
ordering both sides to turn over their
finances something Hunter fought hard
against and it'll have to appear in
person at all future court dates worse
the judge says he has to wear pants
so leave it to a baby mama to finally
take Hunter in the bidens down because
the feds certainly aren't doing it which
leads us to that Infamous laptop letter
that conveniently popped up right before
the last election the one signed by more
than 50 Intel officers AKA lying sacks
of
who said the laptop was Russian disinfo
Secretary of State Anthony blinken was a
Biden campaign advisor at the time and
it alleged to have been The Mastermind
but on Special Report he denied it
because one of the great benefits of his
job is that he doesn't do politics
one of the great benefits of this job is
that I don't do politics and don't don't
engage in it but with regard to uh to
that letter
um I didn't wasn't my idea didn't ask
for it didn't solicit it oh a campaign
advisor is a weird job for someone who
doesn't do politics I mean that's like
when I wore a g string to a bachelorette
party but I wasn't the stripper
in fact it's just like that
but look Hunter's personal sexual habits
aren't my concern sleep with all the
hookers and strippers you want that was
my mom's advice when I turned 15.
but your dad should stop lecturing us on
compassion tolerance and caring for
other people's brats when he can't do it
himself right Joe
no no no look look compassion come on
I mean but you got to have some
compassion for a hunter too
I mean the Kid Likes strippers what can
I say
but 20 grand a month that's too much
I mean what do they get from one of
those lap dances twenty dollars I should
have to do 33.3 dances a day seven days
a week I mean that's too much for a
single mom
um but I I don't know what hunter likes
about these dances anyway
I'd rather have you just sit on my lap
and let me chew on your ponytail
welcome tonight's guests When She Bangs
the gavel criminals unravel co-host of
the five judging Bureau
he told Nike to just do it it meaning
stick a size 16 shoe up your ass host of
The Price and Splendor of freedom on Fox
Nation and his Canter Frida
she only wears pink when the cleaners
can't remove the blood stains Fox News
contributor captive
and finally he's back he shaves with a
riding mower my massive sidekick in the
NWA World Heavyweight Champion Tyrese
judge how you doing tonight everything
good everything's good I'm here with you
what could be better you know nothing
could be better right I don't think so
maybe if we were wasted I don't do that
I know I know I know so what do you make
of this these new developments into
Hunter Camp is this going anywhere no
you know why I love what's happening
because this family court judge is going
to do what the Department of Justice the
IRS the FBI have not been able to do and
she's basically saying Hunter I want all
of your records I want to know all your
income I even want to know who's paying
you for these paintings and she has a
right to do that I did that as a family
court judge and you know she's going to
get to the bottom of it and I don't like
the way you're handling the case his
lawyers are being rude they're redacting
everything I mean she's not taking any
crap and at the end of the day it's
Hunter who started this Hunter is the
one who went for a reduction of
modification downward modification of
support so he asked for it so you know
what she says from now do you got to
show up none of this might you know I'm
a big chat you're not a big shot you're
a dirt bag and you're a deadbeat do you
ever think that yeah
yeah everything Joe's gonna accept that
little girl as a granddaughter you know
the the pain and the emotional
psychological damage that they're doing
to this child maybe not now but in a
couple of years when she realizes they
shunned her that they had stockings on
the fireplace for every kid even the dog
every grandchild but not her what's
wrong with her this is DNA it's 99.9
certain she is his daughter yeah shame
on them dogs don't even know about
Christmas yeah they don't they don't
they like the bones well who doesn't and
it's
and it's welcome to the show first time
I'm pretty excited yeah I'm glad you are
do you ever think you'd be talking about
this topic oh yeah I mean it's it's
um I would just say this no one is above
the law yeah you know even if even if
you're the most you know important or
famous person in the world and you
cannot get away for being a bad dad yeah
and now you're going to a quarter reduce
the money I mean you're the son of the
president yes what are you what are you
doing yeah you know I'm it's confusing
but I would just say you know take
responsibility people will respect you
more uh but I have zero respect now yeah
yeah when did you uh when did you decide
to change your name to Freedom oh so is
it actually a funny story so I remember
if you coming here for the first time uh
going to a high school after the
practice all my teammates were just like
going around and you know they were just
after the practice they were just you
know tweeting and posting stuff and I
saw one of my teammates post he was
criticizing the president I turned
around immediately this was 2009 I
turned around I'm like dude what are you
doing he said what happened I was like I
saw your post and he said okay I was
like well you might be in jail tomorrow
because you were criticizing the
president all my teammates were laughing
they were like this is not turkey this
is America
I'm like what are you talking about I
was like yeah we have freedom of speech
freedom of religion here just because of
you criticize the government or the
president you're not going to be in jail
the next day that is so true when you
talk to people that come here like my
wife is uh from Russia and she's always
like shut up Greg
no free speech for you about everything
everything she tells me I'm at home says
you're gonna get a red fan I think you
just want me to shut up yeah I was like
I don't think that's because she's
Russia
all right cat what do you make of this
stuff I don't care who Hunter has sex
with but you know what take
responsibility I know that if I knocked
up a stripper I would take
responsibility
yeah maybe yeah people do always say
that about you yeah yeah
um I'm just
I'm a little confused by wouldn't it
okay let's just say whatever he doesn't
care he's a bad guy but would it have
just been easier to say okay I'll hang
out with a kid every once in a while
right exactly take him to McDonald's
just pretend to care yes that's what my
parents did because now
because now everybody knows that you're
a jerk and you know it's gonna be one
really strange little family scrapbook
it's just a bunch of news clippings of
your dad saying he doesn't want you you
know what you made me think Hunter has
got to play the long game in 20 years
she's going to have female friends who
are in their 20s kaching whoa yeah whoa
whoa I mean there's just no defense when
he can make you know half a million
dollars blowing paint out with a straw
yes like you must have enough money for
a straw and some paint exactly and you
could use that with your little kid who
will in 20 years have black friends whoa
Iris hot friends man yeah I'm I'm gonna
have to kill you
welcome back by the way you're not
coming to the birthday parties
um
you know what bothers me because this is
about character
okay because they love to talk about the
mother's job somehow that makes it
different not being a dad
one of my lovely children's mother was a
stripper and I raise her and love her to
death and has nothing to do with her
mom's job right because I have character
this has no character yeah and what's
worse you learn it from his father um
because you're the president of the
United States
your wife is a doctor she's so smart
you are grandma and Dr Grandpa Grandpa
whatever the hell neither one of you has
stepped up yeah because your argument is
and this is why the first world problems
well she's a stripper well what are you
he's a drug addict you're a liar and
you're a pretend doctor so there should
be plenty of room
creative
activity
yeah she didn't ask to come in the world
this way and this is a typical another
reason why he's a punk
only the worst dudes you know say dumb
stuff like well I don't even remember
having sex with her well DNA says you
did bruh so step up and be a man I can
raise mine and my daddy well sea turtle
you know he just gave me the he gave me
the DNA he said good luck yeah this dude
your father is the president of the
United States and you want to tell us
you slept on a cot yeah when you flew on
Air Force One to Ireland and you got
there and you expect us to believe that
all they had for you was a cot yeah yeah
maybe after they dragged you out of the
other rooms were you scared and attacked
everybody it just goes back to this is
about character yeah shame on them this
none of this should be the light you're
the president United States amen yeah if
any family could take care of this kid
if Barack Obama did this this would be
front page yeah oh yeah president Trump
front page Bill Clinton would have done
it but for some reason everybody's fine
with them constantly saying
well his daughter from the stripper yeah
how is that any better from being from a
secretary or anybody else the job of the
mom is at the door better it's better
than being from a secretary because I
don't know why the bad guy in this is
the son of the president not the mother
of the child you got it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else